[Music]
[Applause]
how many of you have ever walked into a
room and wondered why did I come here in
the first place
or maybe you left something behind your
pencil case for example and you have to
circle the entire house before coming
back to the place where you originally
started only to find it sitting right
there anyone had any similar experiences
great for me it's things like this that
define my life my friends know me for
continuously losing my water bottle
among other things I am in every sense
of the word a scatterbrain and I was
feeling pretty foolish about it myself
until I read this article about this
book called where good ideas come from
the natural history of innovation and in
it the author Steven Johnson compares
settlements of different types alike
cities and towns noting that as cities
get bigger they generate ideas at a
faster clip why because of the numbers
the increase in number of ideas in a
fixed area so in our context a
scatterbrain can be seen as a metropolis
with bits of disorganized information
floating around constantly crashing into
each other it's messy but it's also more
likely for two unrelated ideas to
collide giving rise to new innovations
like hip-hop ballet fusion or the use of
math to formulate a harmonic melody so
in essence a scatterbrain then becomes
the source of creativity and innovation
and therefore it's just as Steven
Johnson said the more disorganized your
brain is the smarter you are now
considering that I had the potential of
being the queen of scatterbrains
I was feeling pretty good about myself
but another part of me started to wonder
hold up if you're such a genius then how
come none of your ideas ever take shape
and that brings us to the greatest
disaster faced by all scatterbrains
flooding it happens internally and
externally
let me explain now I don't know about
you but 90% of the best ideas I have
ever had have come to me when I'm in the
shower
so I might have an English literature
essay due the next day and I might be
shampooing my hair when all of a sudden
this line pops up in my head
despite his high status Otello the
tragic hero eventually Falls to his doom
due to jealousy his greatest her Mercia
and I'm like yes this will make a
top-notch literature sentence so I
quickly finish showering and my clothes
on see myself at my table pen and paper
in hand ready to write the golden essay
and I reach into my head to find that
line only to find lyrics to a Michael
Jackson song or images from the last
movie I watched in the end I'm just left
there thinking hmm I have this really
nice way of saying Otello dies what was
it again my mind is so flooded that I
can't find that sentence I came up with
just two minutes ago the second type of
flooding happens externally by people
putting things in your brain so for
example I might be on my way to school
and my mum would say hey why don't you
buy this chocolate from this particular
shop because apparently it tastes really
good and then I'd go to school and I'd
get a attacked by an arsenal of math
equations and then I might go to the
lunch and my friends would give me this
list of movies to remember to watch over
the weekend and the day would go on and
on with things piling in my head until
finally it looks something like this
this my friends is what a scatterbrain
looks like all those pieces of paper are
bits of information that people put in
your brain and sometimes they go in
sometimes they don't and in this mess
the chances of remembering to look at
the information that says remember your
bottle well that's pretty slim yet
strangely enough
my memory becomes flawless when it comes
to things like remembering dialogues
from movie or random facts for example
did you know that the word for pineapple
in a lot of the languages of the world
sounds something like uh Nonna's so for
example in Hindi it's an Una's in French
it's a non-us in Indonesian it's non-us
it's completely useless fact like I'm
probably never gonna use it maybe I
might I don't know so but I remember it
super clearly and that got me thinking
why why is it I can remember the
translation for pineapple but I can't
remember a sentence I came up with just
two minutes ago forget that I can't even
remember not to leave my water bottle
behind so after a lot of frustration and
contemplation I was able to condense it
down into three main points sequence
Association and iteration sigh what does
it mean
well sequence is your ability to find a
logical pattern in the information that
you have to remember Association is when
you link that information with something
weird striking memorable to make it
speak in your brain an iteration is when
you've repeated so many times that it
automatically gets stuck in your head
that's why when I go like hello can you
hear me I bet half of the people in this
room are able to sing along because
they've heard it a thousand times or
when I say the word frozen you
immediately think of a blonde girl in a
blue dress singing let it go let it go
your brain is able to pick up that
specific information and display it at
the right moment so that's four things
we don't really need to remember how
about the things that are really
required
well we applied the same three rules in
fact man has been using it throughout
history before the time of writing there
was the oral tradition where the history
of civilizations was passed down through
songs and hints forget history think
about yourself
back in nursery your teachers to use
nursery rhymes to teach her things like
alphabets parts of the bodies numbers
all these rhymes had sequence could be
associated something interesting and if
it was iterated enough times it'll
automatically get stuck in your head
first time I was formally introduced to
memory techniques was when I was in
sixth grade and I was going through a
phase where I had somehow gotten it into
my head that I could not continue living
unless I learned Japanese so one day I
was in the kitchen with my mom who was
cooking and I was trying to learn the
numbers 1 to 10 in Japanese emphasis on
the word trying I I was going nowhere
but I wasn't about to give up anytime
soon so I was rambling on and on and my
mom must have gotten fed up because at
one point she gently interrupted me and
she was like Trishna
why don't you make a story out of it and
I was like mother how the heck am I
supposed to make a story out of this and
she was like okay think of it this way
one in Japanese is et and two is me
together they sound something like an e
Cheney and I was like okay see what you
did there and I went ahead and I created
a story of my own and it goes something
like this once upon a time there was a
kid named make now Meg had a very itchy
knee and it was a very sunny day so she
was feeling really sleepy and she began
to yawn a lot so to wake herself up she
decided to go out and play so she went
outside and she started playing with
some rocks
Roku but then she decided Nana I've got
a stop because it had begun raining and
she had caught a cold
and she was sneezing like Hachi so she
went to find shelter in the nearest
store but when she got there she found a
really long queue but the shop owner who
was designing let her go in
first the end it's a completely weird
useless story but that's kind of what
made it stick there was a sequence of
events i associated each word with a
homophone and if I repeat it enough
times it'll automatically get stuck in
my brain
perfect right with the technique like
this I could remember anything
unfortunately no I couldn't remember
things when I didn't remember that I had
something to remember my water bottle
for instance so while I was excelling in
class where I had to remember things
like lists and definitions outside I was
still a complete mess and then when I
entered junior high
the BBC's Sherlock Holmes TV show came
out and its protagonist Sherlock Holmes
had the one thing I had always longed
for an awesome memory he called it his
mind palace he could do this thing where
within a matter of seconds he could come
out with the exact date place and time a
murder happened 20 years ago I was blown
away so I did the first thing any girl
of my generation would do I googled him
and I found out that his memory
technique was quite a commonly used one
called method of loci it uses what's
known as spatial memory which is your
ability to remember geographical spaces
in detail so for example you know every
nook and cranny in your room or maybe
something bigger you know all the roads
in a certain area so when I found out I
was ecstatic and I wanted to put it to
immediate use and the most current
problem I was having at the time was my
tendency to lose things I was carrying
with me my water bottle for instance so
I developed a routine wherein for
leaving a place I would take a walk
around school in my head what do I mean
well the first step to creating a mind
Palace is picking a location you are
really familiar with and for me personal
I know all the rooms in my school so I
made the school my mind palace and I
associated each room with objects I
tended to lose a lot so for example the
calculator I would associate with the
math room my USB with the computer room
and my bottle with the lost-and-found
and on and on so before leaving a room I
would mentally take a walk around each
of these rooms and check to see if I had
the Associated object on me at the time
so for example I would first go to the
math room associated with the calculator
do I have it yes and then move on to the
next room's checking to see if I had
each object until finally I reached a
lost-and-found associated with bottle do
I have the bottle yes complete obviously
this is a highly simplified version of
the actual thing but it's one way of
putting the technique to use and here
too we can see site we can see the
sequence of rooms and how each room is
associated with an object and if it's if
I walk through these rooms enough times
all of it will automatically get stuck
in my head so that's the bottle problem
solved and I also managed to retain my
scatterbrain genius of being able to
find anything I need in the metropolitan
mess of my mind
using these memory techniques so let's
come back to the present hello everyone
my name is Trisha I am 17 years old and
I am a complete scatter brain but I
manage my life pretty well using my new
and refined memory techniques well it's
not a hundred percent foolproof but at
least I can say with confidence I will
never have to ask myself this question
again thank you
[Applause]